torture it's the thing that happens to
Mel Gibson in all his movies
this little piggy stayed home Wow that
is awful
although I will say the past decade of
Mel Gibson's life has made those clips
slightly more enjoyable to watch sadly
torture is not just something that
happens to Mel Gibson it's also been
practiced by the United States as
President Obama admitted last summer in
a bizarre manner in the immediate
aftermath of 9/11 we did some things
that were wrong we did a whole lot of
things that were right but we tortured
some folks that's a weird way to phrase
that you said what you're quoting a
horrifying Andy Griffith episode you see
Opie things got a little out of hand
down at the jailhouse and Barney and I
well we tortured some folks we tortured
those folks good okay
the president's comments were triggered
by the Senate intelligence committees
massive 6700 page report on the CIA's
detention and interrogation program the
full report remains classified but a 500
page summary was released in December
and it is even actually available on
Amazon and you should get a copy
especially if you're looking for a truly
terrible book club pick because this has
got to be right up there with a lawn
mower repair manual or Bill Cosby's
memoir time flies you know when time
really flies when you lose consciousness
for three hours and wake up in Bill
Cosby's limo but the point is clearly
most people have not read this summary
that's not particularly shocking what is
shocking is that many of those actually
involved in the programs even former
director of the CIA Porter Goss have not
read it either I have not read a word of
the report I have not read a word of any
of this stuff how how have you not read
it you're in it 81 times
spoiler alert buy the story spoiler
alert
you can do it though just knock out a
chapter a night and if you can't find
the time to sit down and read it don't
worry we've made an audiobook version
with Academy award-winning actress Helen
Mirren reading the report for you and
I'm not kidding about that she did it
for us take a listen
the CIA placed individuals with no
applicable experience or training in
senior detention and interrogation roles
yes reading the report that you should
have already read for you Porter Goss so
put it on in your car and King listen to
it and look I know no one no one wants
to read this or talk about what's in it
but there are a few things in here that
we all should really grapple with
because as a recent poll revealed a lot
of us may have some dangerous
misconceptions about torture 69% of
Americans told us they consider
waterboarding to be torture but nearly
half 49% said such tactics are sometimes
justified and more than half 57 percent
said these interrogation techniques
often or sometimes provide reliable
information that can help prevent terror
attacks 57% of us are confident that
torture works that is a lot according to
one poll only 46% of Americans are
confident in the big bang theory which
is crazy because that is literally
explained to us every week in the
opening credits of the big bang thing
and sadly there is no sitcom theme that
explains torture to us at least not
since they canceled two guys a girl and
a black site prison and if you're
thinking why are we talking about this
now didn't we pass a law banning all
those enhanced interrogation techniques
well it turns out no we didn't we
checked and the only restrictions put in
place were by an executive order
President Obama signed in 2009 requiring
interrogations to follow the Army Field
Manual and that's it and executive
orders can be instantly overturned as
soon as the president leaves office and
think about that that means president
Lindsey Graham could undo that on his
first day in office and to be honest
that just seemed like a nice thing to do
for him it he can put that image in a
frame and he can look at it while he's
not being president for the rest of his
life but let let's look at the report
together because it challenges a lot of
the assumptions in that poll first we
did a lot more than just waterboarding
we learned that one CIA officer played
Russian roulette with a detainee another
threatened a detainee with a gun and a
power drill we learned at least five
detainees were subjected to so-called
rectal rehydration or feeding through
the rectum with no medical necessity yes
forced rectal rehydration and the
details of that in a footnote of this
report are so graphic not even Helen
Mirren can make them sound appealing
maajid khan's lunch tray consisting of
hummus pasta with sauce nuts and raisins
was pureed and rectally infused just
trying not to think about that the next
time you eat hummus in fact I feel like
I should preemptively apologize to the
Sabra hummus brands because your sales
are about to drop quite noticeably and
it doesn't stop there the report also
cites the tragic case of ghoul ramen a
completely innocent man picked up in a
case of mistaken identity who was
shackled to the wall of his cell and
later found dead likely from hypothermia
and at this point we could all probably
do with hearing Helen Mirren reading
something a little more pleasant maybe
some Beatrix Potter Flopsy Mopsy and
Cottontail
good little bunnies went down the lane
to gather blackberries Oh Thank You
Helen that's so much nicer please tell
me more about the bunnies
but while Flopsy Mopsy and Cottontail
were on their way to pick blackberries
peter was chained to a wall in Farmer
McGregor's basement
he'd been badly beaten and a tray of
carrots and raisins was pureed and
rectally in fumes about you for years
you're a monster look you may think as
57% of you evidently do then at least
those tough techniques provided us with
reliable intelligence well not so much
the reports most damning conclusion is
that the tactics were ineffective
despite the CIA's claimed at 20
detainees subjected to them shared
crucial information some of which led to
Osama bin Laden
our staff reviewed every one of the 20
cases and not a single case holds up
torture is one of those things that is
advertised to something that works but
doesn't like a Ford truck or all those
weird bottles of horny goat weed
available at your local bodega but but
maybe the reason that so many of us
innately believe that torture works is
because it does on TV all the time look
at 24 Jack Bauer repeatedly saved
American lives while behaving like this
you're gonna tell me what I want to know
you're gonna start losing your fingers
one by one
where
you probably don't think that any forces
towel down your throat trust me I can
Emmy for Best Drama 2006 beat The
Sopranos great show look torture works
on 24 and in movies because it has to
it's a dramatic device to move the plot
along but art terror experts and they'll
tell you it's one of those movie tropes
that's got no basis in real life like a
wedding being interrupted or someone
this handsome feeling sad or or this
character being partisan it works
because they just says it does and we're
supposed to take it and yet even
supposedly smart people like Antonin
Scalia an ill-tempered bullfrog in a
robe they cite 24 as evidence that
torture could be justified he said Jack
Bauer saved Los Angeles he saved
hundreds of thousands of lives is any
jury going to convict Jack Bauer I don't
think so
and look Justice Scalia just because
Kiefer Sutherland does something on
camera does not mean it's a great idea
unless of course that thing is him
drunkenly running into a Christmas tree
explain everything
[Applause]
yes yes on December 25th we should no
longer celebrate the birth of Christ we
should celebrate that look it's clearly
not all 24s fault
some people continue to insist that our
tactics saved lives citing two
particular cases no Karla chick Mohammad
and Abu Zubaydah provided the
overwhelming majority of reports on al
Qaeda both of them were uncooperative at
first the application of enhanced
interrogation techniques specifically
waterboarding especially in the case of
Khalid Sheikh Mohammed it's what really
persuaded him he needed to cooperate
look I know what you're thinking that is
a reasonable statement from a famously
reasonable man but but let's just look
at those two examples first Abu Zubaydah
the CIA of claims that subjecting him to
enhanced interrogation disrupted two
plots but it turns out he disclosed
those plots before he was waterboarded
and the reports now tells us that they
were judged to be infeasible those plots
and in one case hilariously infeasible
because it concerned two would-be
terrorists who had and this is true
proposed a plot based on a satirical
internet article entitled how to make an
h-bomb which instructed people to enrich
uranium by placing it in a bucket
attaching it to a six-foot rope and
swinging it around your head as fast as
possible for 45 minutes and we all know
that is not how to make an h-bomb that
is the brewing process for Bud Light
line
a scientific fact it's how they do it
now hospital shaykh muhammad he did come
he did give us information after he was
waterboarded that's true
but he's worth noting the quality of
that information he told investigators
that he had sent Abu Issa a Brittani to
Montana to recruit african-american
Muslim converts the FBI scrambles
launches a massive investigation in
Montana trying to find these supposed
black al-qaeda operatives but the FBI
found nothing
KSM was lying yeah of course he was
lying what part of the phrase recruiting
african-american Muslims in Montana did
not make you called instantly
even this week we've learned that the
most famous black person from Montana
may actually be white none of this is to
say that we don't need information from
detainees but if you want to see how to
get it without torture just watch a
former FBI agents Jack Cloonan who
worked in the bin Laden unit show you
how it's done you want to be able to
build a rapport with somebody you are
their salvation because their life as
they know it is over
something I can do for your kids you
concerned about them you want the magic
kid I'll get them educated what do you
want tell me what you want scrip for me
your exit strategy how do you extricate
yourself from this terrible situation by
the way that you put yourself in now you
can't go back home Kenyon no so let's
make peace with that let me help you
find this strategy to give you a life
holy I would tell that man any of
my secrets the fun name I have my
glasses is fixing mcpeepers I want to
try to bleach my anus with Crest
Whitestrips
every day at 2:00 p.m. I cheer myself up
by silently eating four marshmallows
from the back at my desk and I call it a
marshmallow party please stop looking at
me I'll tell you anything so look there
is no proof that torture does any good
but there is real proof that it has
serious harm to America's image overseas
references to American torture show up
everywhere from terrorist recruiting
tools to statements from North Korea who
have called our techniques brutal
medieval and the most insulting thing
about that is that knowing them they
probably meant it as a compliment and
the problem is the rules we have on the
books to stop us from returning to the
dark days of torture are in one easily
reversible executive order now as it
happens John McCain and Diane Feinstein
have proposed an amendment you up for a
vote next week which puts the most basic
parts of the president's executive order
into actual law and we should pass that
because if we don't there is no
guarantee that the next president will
uphold the ban in fact we asked all
fourteen declared candidates whether
they would consider overturning the
president's order and only four of them
told us definitively that they would
definitely keep it in place as for the
rest they either ignored us or avoided
answering directly which is very
frustrating because we need that
information badly from them and the
problem is we can't torture them to get
it because as this report more than
proves that doesn't work
here's the thing if enhanced
interrogation were not torture which it
is and even if torture did work which it
doesn't America should not be a country
that tortures people because it is
brutal
it is medieval and it is beneath us and
when the rest of the world thinks about
America they should not think of this
because that's not what this country is
about they should be thinking about this
[Applause]
Christmas tree
you